we already talked about the
discrepancies between the exit polls and
the reported results in some key states
in the 2016 presidential election that
were outside of the margin of error
which is unusual to say the least but
there's another aspect to this entire
rigged election thing that I want to
talk about today and that has everything
to do with voter suppression right
there's no doubt about the whole point
of voter ID and reducing early voting
it's all about helping Republicans let
me remind you when republican
pennsylvania state Rep Mike Turzai
admitted that voter ID is something to
help Republicans in front of cameras in
a speech this is just a reminder we've
played this before we are focused on
making sure that we meet our obligations
that we've talked about for years
pro-second amendment the castle doctrine
son first pro-life legislation abortion
facility regulations in 22 years done
voter ID which is gonna allow Governor
Romney to win the state of Pennsylvania
Don yeah voter ID done now ahead of
election day media outlets may be
expressed some tepid concern about the
issue of voter suppression but the
analysis has essentially disappeared
since Donald Trump won the electoral
college election so here's an example ok
we can talk through it in Wisconsin
Donald Trump one by one percent of the
vote that worked out to just over 27,000
votes it's very very little remember
that until 2013 the states voting laws
were covered by the Voting Rights Act of
1965 there was this provision which
we've talked about which required that
if local or state uh municipalities uh
agencies wanted to change voting
practices it had to be cleared with the
federal government right after the
Supreme Court removed federal oversight
of voting laws Wisconsin went in
immediately passed a law requiring photo
ID to register as well as a photo ID to
vote state officials repeatedly appeared
in
of a federal district judge to answer
for four unfairly and specifically
burdening democratic leaning voters with
these restrictions and look at the
impact democratic-leaning Milwaukee saw
a 41,000 voter reduction in turn out the
city elections chief was asked about
what caused this and said it was mostly
because of the new voting obstacles
27,000 vote win for Donald Trump 41,000
vote drop in turnout and estimates show
that nearly 300,000 voters did not have
the photo ID necessary under this new
voting regime now Pat people will say
but David it's free IDs just get the
free ID we've talked many times that is
not the way it works many times in order
to get the free ID you need to maybe
travel who does that mostly impact
people who have less money who tend to
baby vote Democratic this impacts people
who were in up particular areas were
public transit may not be as good many
times you have to get documents in order
to get your photo ID which in and of
themselves are not free like a birth
certificate and we've talked about this
before and all of these costs can be
interpreted as a poll tax which is not
only unjust it's also banned by the
twenty fourth amendment yeah you know a
lot of people are saying that we're just
complaining about the results of the
election it's not about who gets the
edge either way it's just about getting
it right because so many people have
fought for the right to vote and to be
disenfranchised so unjustly it's just
not right and even when President Obama
won we report on voted voting
irregularities voting supporter
suppression voter IDs etcetera now
here's another example north carolina
right trump won in north carolina by
three point eight percent which worked
out to a little over a hundred and
seventy seven thousand votes black
turnout during early voting declined by
over eight percent amounting to about
sixty thousand fewer votes now you might
say well that doesn't alone account for
anything because Trump won by a hundred
and seventy seven thousand and you're
only talking about sixty thousand fewer
votes well compare that to increased
voter turnout in states that didn't
change the voting rules like for example
in Louisiana
Louisiana did not change voting rules
after the Supreme Court decision on the
Voting Rights Act black turnout was up
north carolina changes voting rules and
early voting etcetera black turnout is
down so although the number was down
60,000 there's a very good chance that
were it not for these voter suppression
laws turnout would have been up making
the difference far more than just the
net decrease of 60,000 voters in North
Carolina the Republican state
legislature cut back big league on
polling locations and early voting hours
we've reported about the purging of
minority voters from registration lists
this is a major major issue there were
countless irregularities with regard to
voter suppression uh and and recently
with these voter ID requirements and of
course in the background of all of this
is my story from last week about these
outside of the margin of error variances
discrepancies between the exit polls and
the reported results so we are going to
stay on top of every aspect of this
story